The joe rogan experience we talked about next week.
Me going back there and shooting bows with him.
Yep.
And talking just about whatever,
you know,
just kind of helmet once he is form.
That's right.
So,
uh,
we're trying to make that happen and,
I just,
you know,
like I said,
if you have somebody's ear,
you just want to be able to tell them what's important to you and that's all I
want to do.
But I can you do that generally better over something I care about,
like archery or running or lifting weights or whatever like that.
So that's my goal,
just to,
you know,
share what's what,
because I feel like I have a pretty good pulse on what's important to sportsmen
and hunters here in North America.
And uh,
so I just want to share that.
Well,
I know Donald Trump junior is an avid archer.
Like he's really into it.
He's an avid hunter and he,
you got a chance to talk to him?
Yeah,
yeah.
Wow.
Quite a quite a while.
Yeah.
He wants to do the podcast,
this podcast.
Yeah.
So he,
he went,
you know,
me,
you and him can talk,
uh,
talk about hunting.
Okay,
we're in dawn.
So the smoke weed first for sure.
Oh for sure.
No total normal.
I mean cause that possible.
How's it possible that you grow up with Donald Trump as your dad?
You've got a golden toilet bowl when that little kid,
that's what I said,
I said,
you know,
I go,
cause I haven't met any of of uh,
Donald's kids except for Don Jr.
So I'm like,
well,
but I follow them on Instagram.
You know,
you kind of get kind of a sort of a feel for what the,
I said,
man,
I go,
you know,
in talking to you,
I said,
it seems weird to say,
but seem like a normal gun,
which is your dad's a billionaire.
I don't know.
Is he a billionaire?
Right.
Yeah.
So doesn't that seem,
it seems surprising.
He's like,
seems like just like we would be right.
Total normal.
I mean he's,
I follow my Instagram,
I see that the pictures of his daughter,
super cute,
the fishing pictures,
but I saw them on Tucker Carlson the other night and I told them this and we
were talking in Vegas and he was like just laying it down for a one minute clip
on Instagram on Tucker Carlson was to Fox News and laying it down and I was
like,
God,
I never really had followed his political or is his public speaking type life.
So I was like,
holy crap,
this guy is pretty dialed in.
It's probably the plan it takes over when he might,
he might,
I mean he's 40 so he's just kind of getting his feet under slides right in that
world and Trump dynasty just like they did with the bushes.
That's right.
Just know all of them.
Clinton's clenches,
you know,
once you're in there it's like that's all they want.
Is that interesting?
It's crazy.
But he,
I would feel,
I mean man,
well that's what it sounded like.
A good guy.
This guy don junior running for president.
He's don junior is very reasonable.
Oh Man.
Totally.
Totally funny.
If he,
if he says one thing wrong,
one thing,
one slip up of a word,
which by the way,
everybody does every day.
I do it every day.
Yeah.
Me Too.
One,
one slip up of the word Corey Knowlton right.
One fuck up like that.
And then this dunce,
I mean,
you,
you see all this is magnified,
ridiculous hate that comes his way.
And the,
uh,
the attacks against him and people are people right now listening to this,
probably yelling at them because they're fucking jaws to Ford.
Here's Bruce,
here's a show.
Okay.